Donald Trump in a somber mood as he
arrived for talks at the g7 the US
president facing hostility from some
leaders over differences on several
international issues but as the meetings
began it seemed common ground on Iran
who has achieved the French president
who's hosting the summit said g7 leaders
agreed that he should talk to Iran on
their behalf we had a discussion on the
wrong with two common lines first no
member of the g7 wants Iran to obtain a
nuclear weapon
second every member of the g7 is
profoundly attached to stability and
peace in the region so we don't want to
take any action which could harm this
and in an unexpected twist iran's
Foreign Minister Mohammad Javad Zarif
arrived from Tehran for talks
two days after meeting macro in Paris
Immanuel macaw has been trying to
mediate in the Iran crisis since the
u.s. pulled out of the 2015 Iran nuclear
deal last year and re imposed sanctions
it wasn't long though before the
apparent g7 unity on Iran was broken
[Music]
Trump has also sent mixed messages about
the us's trade war with China a dispute
that shaking the world economy and
worrying g7 leaders Trump told reporters
that he had second thoughts about us
tariffs on Beijing the White House later
said that what he meant was that he had
regretted not hiking those tariffs
higher positions were clearer in Trump's
first meeting with a British prime
minister Trump threw his support behind
brexit and Boris Johnson and promised an
attractive trade deal if the UK leaves
the EU Michel will undoubtedly hope the
unscheduled invitation to iran's Foreign
Minister could be a step to D escalating
tensions in the region even though for
now Zarif says he has no plans to meet
the US delegation or Trump
Natasha Butler al Jazeera Barret's